- Before we started the show,
I was talking about the
five Gs with my guys.
Can we go through the five Gs?
- Of course I love the five Gs.
- I know, I know.
Take it away.
("Rubin Report" intro music)
I'm Dave Rubin, and
joining me today is author
of the world-famous book,
"Rich Dad, Poor Dad"
and author of the brand new
book, "Capitalist Manifesto:
"How Entrepreneurs
Can Save Capitalism".
Robert Kiyosaki welcome
to "The Ruben Report".
- Well, thank you, honored
to be on your program.
You're doing a great
job. Thank you.
- Oh, I appreciate that.
Well, I am glad to have you on
because in my last book I
did one chapter on capitalism
to try to save capitalism,
but your whole
life has been about
trying to save capitalism.
So before we get into
capitalism itself,
give me a little bit of
your bio for the people
that maybe have not read it
because it's quite extraordinary
and pretty much explains exactly
why you care about the
things that you write about.
- Right. It's more
than capitalism, David,
I'm fighting for our freedom.
And there's a fine
line, you know,
between that and capitalism.
But my background is,
I'm fourth-generation
Japanese-American.
And the reason I say that is,
during the Vietnam War
I was a U.S. Marine,
and some people think,
"You fought for the
Japanese Marine Corps?"
(both laughing)
I always thought that was funny.
And then I've been accused
of being a white supremacist
because I support freedom,
I support capitalism.
I said, "I looked
in the mirror,"
I said, "well, I'm still
not white." (chuckles)
It's just,
it's amazing how
little people know,
it shocks me.
So anyway, my background is
I'm fourth-generation
Japanese-American,
I was raised in Hawaii
and I had the misfortune
or good fortune to go
to a rich kid school,
a rich white kid school
in a little town
called Hilo, Hawaii.
So on one side of
the street, I mean,
exactly opposite was
Hilo Union School,
and Hilo Union School was
for all the minorities,
the Japanese, the
Chinese, the Filipino,
the Portuguese and all this.
And directly across the street
was Riverside School
for the rich kids.
And I just, my father was
head of education poor dad,
and he didn't gyrate,
manipulate anything,
I just happened to
fall into the district
with the rich kids school.
I was nine years old, I'm going,
"Well, how come some
people are rich,
"and why are some people poor?"
And as you know, David,
one of the biggest
problems we have today
is this gap between
rich and poor.
It sets up revolution,
and I don't think
that's a mistake.
So I go to this
rich kid's school,
and I asked the teachers,
"Well, how do I get rich?"
Well, she said, "You
stay in school."
I said, "My poor dad
stayed in school,
he's still poor." (laughs)
You know how kids are, they go,
"(speaking in foreign language),
"what's happening here?"
- Yeah.
- So that's how the story of
"Rich Dad, Poor Dad" started.
But the real test
of the thing was
that was that movie,
"Caddyshack", you
know, years ago,
Chevy Chase and all those
characters. (laughs)
- I've seen it
roughly 4,000 times.
- But that's the classic story
of rich and poor, you know.
So by 10, I take up the game
of golf and I have to hitchhike
to the country club,
but I have to sit
in the caddy shack
and my classmates are
in the country club.
And I keep asking
myself again, you know,
(speaking in foreign language),
how come some people are rich
and some people are poor?
And it kind of became
my lifelong quest
and question on that.
I did go to military school.
I mean, I was a
horrible student,
but I got congressional
nominations, the Naval Academy
and U.S. Merch Marine
Academy in New York.
I took Merch Marine Academy.
And in 1965, when I went there,
it's a purely, it's one of
the five federal academies
of Air Force, Army, Navy,
Coast Guard, anyway.
This is the book
they had me read.
So while my peers are going
through traditional Snowflake U,
are studying Keynes and
Adam Smith and (indistinct),
my economics teacher at
the academy had us read,
Marx, Hitler, Mao,
Stalin, Lennon.
So at 18 years old, Dave,
I'm effed up, you know,
I'm going "Holy Mackerel."
And that's when the
kinda lights go on,
I'm 18 years old,
military school,
I'm being yelled at screamed at.
And I realized that most of
my friends are communists,
but they don't know it.
I'm not saying
they're bad people,
just like, can you be a Hindu,
can you be Christian,
can you be Muslim,
can be Jewish?
Economics is
basically a religion.
That's all it is.
So the moment my economics
teacher at the military school
is teaching me this
stuff, I'm going,
"Most school teachers
are Marxists."
And that's kind of when
the lights kept going on.
So I graduated 1969.
My background is oil,
so I do know what I'm talking
about when it comes to oil.
So when that sucker Biden cut
off the Keystone XL Pipeline,
I said, "That man's a communist
"'cause I know
what he was up to."
I mean, I'm an oil guy,
I sell for Standard Oil.
My first port of call
was Valdez Alaska,
the Alaska Pipeline in 1969,
I'm going "Holy Mackerel."
Then I could see communism
seeping into our country,
plus I'm so old,
Columbia University
was one of the first ones that
had the riots in the '60s,
and the riots then spread
through all the colleges
throughout United States.
So that when you
read this book here,
you'll find out that in 1930
communism came into America
from the Frankfurt School
and they embedded themselves
in Columbia University's
Teachers College.
And so that was in 1930s
and as a baby boomer
I go to Vietnam
twice '66 and '72,
I fly for the U.S. Marine Corps
not the Japanese Marine Corps,
but the U.S. Marine Corps.
- Noted, I will
make note of that
in the comment section.
- I'm fighting for freedom.
I am fighting for freedom,
and I'm watching the news, Dave,
what our press was reporting
wasn't what was happening.
And the only reason I knew that,
because I fought in the battles
they were describing
on television.
So this sounded like blaspheme,
so when Walter
Cronkite, you know,
the Grand Puba of journalism,
"And that tonight is
the CBS Evening News."
I said, "You're lying to us."
And that's, you know,
Dave, that's when I went,
"We're being screwed."
And I realized this book
is an 1848 was coming true,
it's only 50 pages.
Most people have never read it.
So that's why-
- All right,
so you've given me a lot
of avenues to go there.
So first, I love that
you started by connecting
capitalism to freedom
because we seem to be
losing both right now.
So to connect this a
little bit directly
to capitalism at the moment,
how do you think capitalism,
or why do you think,
perhaps, that capitalism
didn't sell itself
well enough right now?
Like the sales people for
capitalism maybe are failing,
and that, seemingly, is
why the ideas of the book
that you keep holding
up, "Communist Manifesto"
for our audio listeners,
seems to be taking off.
- Well, when I wrote
"Rich Dad, Poor Dad"
which came out in 1997,
it was turned down
by every one of those
Marxist book editors
in New York (laughs).
- Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
- You know what
I'm talking about.
- They're all crumbling now,
so you're getting
your just rewards.
- And I asked them, I
asked the question in 1997,
I published the book,
"So what does school
teach you about money?"
Why not?
And then that's when those
Marxists in New York City
couldn't answer the
question and said,
"Well, you don't know what
you're talking about."
And I said, "What do you mean?"
He says, "Well, you talk about
the rich not paying taxes."
I said, "That's correct."
So if you understand taxes,
taxes came in in 1913
with the creation
of the Federal Reserve Bank,
the Fed is a central bank.
Doesn't that send chills
up and down your spine?
So in 1913-
- It does now. It does now.
Maybe it didn't 10 years ago,
but I was very
different 10 years ago.
- And, Dave, 10 years ago,
if you and I were having
this conversation,
the little white men in
the little rubber suit
would be dragging
me out the door.
(both laughing)
So I said, you know, I mean,
"What did they teach
you about money?"
And they go, "Nothing."
I said, "Ever asked
yourself why?"
"Well, no, 'cause money is,
"the love of money is
the root of all evil."
Some of that Christian stuff.
I'm going, "I'm not
knocking Christians,
"I'm just saying, you know,
"it's a lot of religious
indoctrination in money.
"If you study money,
"that means you're
gonna be greedy, evil,
"and be a sex trafficker
or something."
I'm going, "Man, there's
so much stuff attached
"to this little
subject called money."
So capitalism to me
is just basically
free market capitalism,
it's freedom.
You wanna be a communist,
knock yourself out.
And most teachers are communist,
they just don't know it.
They don't understand
that taxes,
what Marx said about a
progressive income tax
is essential for the
spread of communism.
You know, it's right
in the book, read it.
- Do you think that they don't,
it's interesting
because you're saying
they don't know that
they're communist,
but do you think they
also fundamentally
don't seem to understand
a certain part of
human psychology,
the way we actually work?
What actually drives us,
the way we wanna
maintain relationships,
that there are
win-wins in business,
things of that nature?
- Well, I'll tell
you what in my,
and I didn't do well in school.
I mean, I went, only reason
I got into Naval Academy
and Merch Marine Academy
is I played football
and I had high SATs.
My grades are terrible.
I just hated school.
I just hated it, but
I got through it.
But teachers live in a
different world, as you know,
they have a different
value system.
It's not good or bad.
So in my family is a number
of advanced degrees you had
made you superior
to those who didn't.
So I used to say to my
dad with a PhD, poor dad.
"PhD, does that stand for
poor, helpless and desperate?"
(both laughing)
And naturally got my mouth
washed out with soap,
if you know what I mean?
And my rich dad
never went to school.
So he was trained as
a small business guy,
started at the age of 13.
So he'd seen, like I said,
when I was in Vietnam,
what was reported on
the news didn't happen.
You know, I was
in those battles.
I was at Quang Tri, Hue,
I fought in Cam Ranh, outside
of Cam Ranh and all this,
it was fake news.
Exactly as Trump says.
And I did write this
book here with my friend,
Donald Trump "Midas Touch".
- Yeah. You've written
two books with him, right?
- Yes, yes.
Great man. Very good man.
I'll tell you a story about him,
people wonder what he's like.
There's no two Donald
Trumps, you know, (laughs)
there's one guy and whoever's
talking to you at that moment
is the real Donald Trump.
He and I used to speak at these
massive real estate conventions.
And one day I got up
on stage with him,
and I made the mistake of saying
there was a person
Leona Helmsley,
they call her the Queen of Mean.
- Oh yeah, I remember, I'm
from New York back then.
- Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
- All the "New York Post"
headlines, "The Daily News,"
the whole thing, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So Leona gets up there and
called people, little people.
- Oh yeah. I remember.
- Oh, yeah.
- It was massive. Yeah.
- So I go on stage,
and I mention the
word little people.
Trump came up on stage
and in front of maybe,
I don't know how many
thousands of people,
10,000, it was at Javits
Center, which is a big place,
he comes up there and he
says in front of everybody,
he says, "Never use
the term little people.
"You treat everybody
with respect."
That's who Donald Trump is.
Now, you'd never guess that
when he calls little Markle,
(both laughing)
lying Hillary and
all this stuff,
but he treats everybody
around him with respect,
except when he is on stage
and on Twitter. (laughs)
- Was it purely both of
your love of capitalism
that brought you guys together?
I mean, you're doing,
you're speaking at
these events and things,
but like when you really
sort of meshed and thought,
"Okay, I can write a
book with this guy."
- No, I mean, Trump
and I real estate guys,
real estate, you
know, real estate guys
don't pay taxes.
I think, you know that.
The rich don't pay taxes.
- There's ways to lose money,
that kind of worked
out sometimes.
- And so when
Hillary said to him,
"And he doesn't pay taxes."
What was his response?
- "I'm smart."
- "That means I'm smart."
(laughs) Listen, I agree.
But remember tax is Marx,
a progressive income tax
is essential for the
spread of communism.
That came in in 1913
with the creation
of the Federal Reserve Bank.
So what else was
created in 1913,
which they don't teach
you in school, was IRS.
So for there to be a central
bank there had to be tax.
Central banks are
essential to communism,
command and control economy.
Everybody knows that except
if you went to school.
- You know, it's interesting,
'cause I can tell you
as somebody that lived
the last eight
years in California,
I now live in the
free state of Florida.
Your facial reaction
was just right.
Now, obviously, I'm not
paying any income tax
and it's like,
man, you know what?
This state is still running,
and actually it's
running quite efficiently
and freedom is flourishing,
and business is flourishing,
and everyone's moving here,
and I have two businesses here,
and it's like, everyone's
fleeing California,
'cause they're just taking
10% at the end of the year.
What they're doing with
it, nobody freaking knows.
- That's really tragic because,
you know, I left Hawaii too.
Hawaii is more Marxist than
California, unfortunately.
Good people, nice weather,
but they don't know
they're Marxist.
They really don't
because they didn't teach
you the difference in school.
But it's a feeling.
Do you know what I mean?
Don't you feel
different in Florida?
- Yes. You're totally right.
I literally feel different.
I'll tell you this.
I felt when I was
landing in the plane,
December 17th, 2021,
when I landed in Florida
I felt something
lift off my chest.
That's how oppressive
I felt that it was,
especially the last two
years in California.
- Yes. I can't believe
what's happening, Dave.
So when I wrote "Rich Dad,
Poor Dad", back in 1997,
I first created the
CASHFLOW board game to teach
financial statements,
income and expense,
statements of cash
flow, you know.
But most people,
they leave school,
they have high GPA,
grade point average,
but they don't have a
financial statement.
Strange, isn't it?
What's more important,
your grade point average
or your financial statement?
And my rich dad
always said to me,
'cause he never
went to the school,
'cause my poor dad was a PhD,
you know: poor,
helpless, desperate,
and my rich dad said, I'm
like 12 years old, he says,
"My bankers never asked me for
my report card yet." (laughs)
(both laughing)
So I wrote "Rich Dad, Poor Dad",
and now I wrote this book here,
the "Capitalist Manifesto",
because capitalism starts
with a financial statement.
Think about it.
How much income,
how many expenses,
assets or liabilities,
and what most people
don't realize,
the U.S. dollar is a liability
against the taxpayer.
That's why 1913, the Fed
was created and so was IRS.
Was that a mistake?
- Probably.
(both laughing)
I think that would
be an understatement,
coming from you probably was.
I mean, it really is
amazing that we don't teach
in public schools in
the United States,
we basically teach no
financial literacy.
I don't know if
you've seen this,
but Ron DeSantis in
Florida just sign something
where they will
start making sure
that you have basic
financial literacy.
And it's like, "Oh, okay,
"we're gonna actually teach
young people something,
"rather than gender."
- I'm glad you say that
because I'm kind
of torn now between
Trump and DeSantis, you know,
because Trump and I are
always for financial education
and all this stuff, but DeSantis
is now gonna start using
some of our things to teach
financial education in Florida.
So it's changing, but we're up
against the teacher's unions.
And that's what this book
"Manifesto" starts with.
I'm not against teachers, I'm
against stealing my freedom.
And the first chapter
is the NEA, National
Extortion Association,
the teachers union, the most
powerful richest teachers,
I mean, most powerful
union in America.
- Do you think maybe they're
losing some power now?
I mean after two years
of COVID it seems
like a lot of people have
maybe turned against them?
I don't know whether it actually
translates into anything,
but people are kind
of fed up with it.
- Well, I think you and
I, you said it earlier,
10 years ago we couldn't be
saying what we're saying now.
10 years ago, I couldn't
have written this book,
but today, you know,
when those communist
call our parents who
question, you know,
critical race theory
and sexual orientation,
whatever they're doing
and they call any parent
who questions
academics terrorists.
I mean, it's your kid, don't
you have a right to say
what you teach your child?
And so that's why this,
the "Manifesto" book here
is how to combat communism
taught in our schools
by teaching capitalism
in our schools,
I mean at home.
I teach, my rich dad taught
me to be a capitalist at home,
not at school.
- I wanna ask you,
so because you talk about
your rich dad, poor dad,
obviously, do you
think it was something
beyond just the education that
defined them in that regard?
Like, do you think it
was a personality trait
or nature versus nurture
that a certain type of person
becomes more interested
in relying on a system
and a certain type of
person is wired to say,
"Hey, I'm gonna go get mine,"
beyond just the education part?
- Well, that's why I say PhD:
poor, helpless, desperate.
They need the job.
They need the paycheck.
They need the benefits.
Whereas when I went to
the U.S. Marine Corps,
it's a different education,
you were taught to lead,
were taught to fight,
were taught to sacrifice.
You know, Nicholson says it
best in "A Few Good Men",
"Santiago's death, while
tragic, saved lives.
"You you can't
handle the truth."
- You can't handle the truth-
- And that's the
U.S. Marine Corp.
- It's weird that he's
now the good guy, huh?
- I loved him.
I mean, I hated it when
I was in it, those SOBs
they were yelling and
screaming at me 24/7.
But when we got to Vietnam,
we were a fighting machine.
I flew the helicopter
gunship and my crew chiefs
were just as important
as the pilots,
we couldn't function
without a team.
And we killed a lot of
people, unfortunately,
but we also had a lot of
atrocities against us too.
And so when I realized I was
in Vietnam for the second time,
went there in '66 and then '72
and we were fighting
for freedom,
that's what we're fighting
for, not capitalism.
Then I come back and I land
at Norton Air Force Base, in
California, January 10th, 1973,
and I get spit on,
get hit by eggs,
by all those hippies from
the Woodstock generation.
I saw this book, which I
read in 1965 coming true.
I said, "We're becoming
a communist nation."
- So what is the best way,
I mean, my audience
watching this,
they like capitalism and
we can sell capitalism
on them all day, they don't
even need it sold on them
in a certain regard,
but what is the best
way to deprogram someone
out of the communist manifesto?
Because that seems to
be where we're at now
with a whole generation
of young people.
- Well, that's a great question
because I learned
to be a capitalist
playing monopoly. (laughs)
You know what I mean?
Ain't that hard, Dave.
(Dave laughing)
- Especially if you're
the one doing the banking,
it's pretty easy.
- I know. Just watch
the banker's hands.
- Exactly. Look over there.
Okay, okay, pretty sweet
to be the government banker.
- It's like like being
the government's
banker. (laughs)
- But it's, you know,
four green houses,
1031 tax-deferred exchange.
I was watching that and
then people kept asking me,
how did my wife when she was
37, I was 47 when we retired,
"So how'd you guys do it?"
And we couldn't explain it
to them because most people
went to school.
They'll learn, go to
school, get a job,
work hard, save
money, get outta debt,
and invest for the long
term in the stock market.
I do none of that.
I don't have to do any of that.
So anyway, we created
the CASHFLOW board game.
It's all because
Maria Montessori
was one of the
great entrepreneur,
I mean educational
entrepreneurs.
She says what the hand
does the mind remembers.
Now think about this.
Could you learn to play
golf, reading a book?
But that's what our
schools are trying to do.
So my wife and I, in
1996, first created
the CASHFLOW board game to
teach the financial statement.
The single most boring subject
in school was accounting.
I mean, it's horrible.
So we made it fun.
We made a game and all this.
So income, expense, assets,
liabilities, cash flow.
Those are three main
financial statements
in a financial statement.
Income statement, which
is income, expense;
balance sheet; asset, liability;
and third's a
statement of cash flow.
That's what the game
is called: CASHFLOW.
So I think he hasn't
agreed to yet,
but DeSantis is considering
using our board game
to teach financial education.
- Wow.
- Because kids like
to play with games.
I did.
- Yeah.
- I hated lecture. I hated it.
- How cool, are you
gonna get a little,
you get a little
residual on that or what?
- Of course, I'm a capitalist.
- You're a capitalist.
I mean, come on.
(Robert laughing)
- Make it, what did
Deng Xiaoping say?
"Get rich is glorious."
I agree with him.
He's a communist, but I
agree with him. (laughs)
- It's not bad.
Do you happen to
remember there was a game
back when I was a kid,
so this was on the Apple IIc
before the Mac or the Mac Book
or any of that, there was
a game on Apple IIc called
"Lemonade Stand".
And that's what it was.
You were running a
little lemonade stand,
there were no graphics,
it told you the weather
and how much sugar
maybe you should buy,
and how many people
were out on the street.
And I learned a lot
from that actually.
- Yeah, yeah. We learn by doing.
And so the CASHFLOW board
game, "Rich Dad, Poor Dad",
the only book that covered the
three financial statements,
income statement, balance
sheet, statement of cash flow.
Those are the three
things that count.
And so when I walk into my
banker today, like in 2008,
when the whole thing
collapsed with Lehman,
and by the way I was on CNN
speaking to Wolf Blitzer saying
Lehman was going down.
- Wow.
- So I called that one.
'Cause I could, you can
see it coming, you know.
And so I was on Lehman and
I called it coming down
and all this stuff, but it's
just a matter of teaching,
you know, all we
have to do is teach.
But the teachers
unions are in the way,
and my poor dad, guess
what he was head of?
Teachers union.
And if you study Marx,
his words were, "Workers
of the world unite."
And my father, and my
rich dad, you know,
this is when I
was like 15 or 16,
his workers were going
on strike in Hawaii,
and rich dad called me, he said,
"Would you mind coming
to manage, you know,
"maintain one of our
desk for us at night?"
So I said, "Sure."
So I went down and
helped my rich dad out,
just be a kid managing the desk
so tourists could
check in and out.
And I got home and my
poor dad gave me hell.
He says, "You're a scab."
(imitating shouting)
- Wow.
- I never saw it like that.
I was just helping a friend out.
But the teachers
union, as you know,
they're as Marxist as they come:
"Workers of the world unite."
So that's all in
"Capitalist Manifesto".
They're just quotes.
They're just quotes
from Stalin, Marx, Mao,
and all those guys.
We were warned, but
nobody paid attention.
- So what do you think the
first step in reversing that is?
If you were talking to,
if there's a 21-year-old
watching this show
that's on the fence, maybe
they just got outta school,
although I know you would
say they don't have to
go to school in the first place.
But let's say they're 21,
they're trying to figure
out what they're gonna do,
where they're gonna live,
what kind of life they want,
but they've been indoctrinated
with a certain
amount of that stuff,
what's the first way we
can get these people,
do you think?
- I think the first to do is
question the indoctrination.
As Thomas Sowell, you
know, from Stanford says,
"It's not education,
it's indoctrination."
Go to school, what do
you learn about money?
Nothing.
Get a job.
Who pays the highest
taxes? Workers.
Pay your taxes.
Rich don't pay taxes.
Get out of debt.
I'm a billion dollars
in debt because in 1971,
when Nixon took the dollar
off the gold standard,
I said, "Thank you, Jesus.
"I'm gonna borrow my ass off now
"and invest in
the stock market."
I don't invest in
the stock market.
I'm not saying you shouldn't,
but having a rich dad,
having financial education,
understanding
financial statements,
understanding cash
flow gave me freedom
that most people will never have
because they've
been indoctrinated:
go to school, get a job, work
hard, save money, pay taxes,
get out of debt and invest
in the stock market.
I don't do any of those
things 'cause I don't have to.
- Do you think there's
a unique moment
for people to follow
your path right now
because so many people, kind of,
don't trust the
system right now?
They see that, oh, they
can just print money,
money's worth less, none
of this really makes sense,
there are no balance sheets.
So more people might
be willing to do
some of the
nontraditional things
that you've been
doing for 30 years.
Well, way more than
30 years actually.
- Well, I think you
said it earlier,
10 years ago, we
couldn't do this.
That wasn't a Zoom.
There wasn't any of this.
You know, this iPhone here
is the most powerful
entrepreneur tool
I ever saw my whole life.
I can text anybody
in the world today.
You know, I can go on
YouTube, get your own podcast.
It's so powerful.
But if your brain isn't
a capitalist brain,
you use it to watch kitty porn
or whatever people do today,
you know what I mean?
It's like, it's also destroying
our society, this iPhone.
That's my concern.
So that's why, you know,
I like Trump and DeSantis,
and I'm voting for
financial education
because that's where
capitalism begins.
Capitalism gives us more freedom
and that's all I
fight for, freedom.
You know, when COVID came out,
they took away our
freedom of speech.
Now they're gonna take away
our second amendment, guns,
disarm the police, whatever
they're talking about,
defund the police,
it's all Marx.
As Mao says, "Politics comes
from the barrel of the gun."
It's all there.
It's in this book here.
Let me read you what Nikita
Khrushchev said in 1959,
"Your children's children
will live under communism.
"You Americans are so gullible.
"No, you won't accept
communism overnight,
"but we will keep feeding
you small doses of socialism
"until you'll finally
wake up and find out
"you already have communism."
That's what we're
finding out today, Dave,
we already are communist.
"We will not have to fight you.
"We will so weaken your economy
"until you fall like overripe
fruit into our hands.
"Nikita Khrushchev,
September 29th, 1959."
And I don't know, Jim Rickards
just made an announcement
that Biden just signed
into executive order
something that CBDC, central
bank digital currency,
were now 100% communists.
Biden just signed
in on March 6, 2022.
We're officially communist now
'cause they took
control of our money.
Central bank digital
currency is a spy system.
It's spyware, it'll
control our entire lives.
So I would check
out Jim Rickards,
he's a good friend of mine,
one of the smartest guys I know.
But today we must be
cautious who our sources
of information are, as you know,
and Jim Rickards is on
the pulse of it right now.
Central bank digital
currency is 100% communist.
- So is that where do you
think all of the stuff
of the last couple
years has led us,
that it was all going to lead us
to this central bank
digital currency
that we'd be tracked and
monitored and spied on.
They could turn us
on, turn us off,
decide who gets in the
economy, who doesn't,
who gets certain
privileges, who doesn't,
that that, it was
all leading to this?
I mean, as you keep
saying, 10 years ago,
we couldn't talk about
this, five years ago
that was pure conspiracy stuff.
- Right, we have to fight back,
I'm a U.S. Marine, not
Japanese Marine. (laughs)
- I'm totally
confident that you were
on the right side.
- Dave.
I can't believe how
stupid some Americans are.
"But you don't have
an American name."
"It's Kiyosaki."
"But that's not American."
I said, (laughs) "Well,
you know, gimme a break."
I met this young woman,
she didn't know who JFK
was, high school graduate.
I mean, what is our
educational system doing?
- I guess it's doing exactly
what the teachers union
wanted it to do, huh?
- You said it.
The drone is circling your
house right now. (laughs)
- Yeah. (laughs)
They're always circling
my house, don't worry.
- So what do you think
the answer, I mean beyond,
okay, so financial literacy,
so we get some young people
to start paying attention
to this stuff.
We don't feed the system
the way that we've been
feeding the system.
Maybe in Florida,
we start, you know,
doing some financial
literacy stuff.
But has the ship sailed
with the federal government
at this point?
I mean, we're in so deep,
and money has been
printed to such an extent,
and as we're talking right
now, inflation's 9.1%,
that's what they're telling us,
which probably means it's more.
I mean, what do you
do about all that
if we're to have hope?
I'm always trying to
give my audience hope.
- Well, it is what this big
word called education is.
So please check
out, Jim Rickards,
his latest thing on the CBDC
is exactly what I've been
warning about in this.
The central bank is Marxist,
and the control of the
currency is the key.
So now they have social
credit scores and all this,
you won't be able
to do anything.
And most Americans are
so apathetic right now,
"Oh, well, so what."
And that's why I
always say to people,
"(speaking in foreign
language), let's fight back."
Marines fight back.
So that's why I'll
back a candidate
like the DeSantis or Trump,
anybody who'll fight.
But I've met some real
wimps out here, oh my God.
I mean, they're terrible.
We have to fight back.
We choose our
politicians wisely.
Even Stalin said, "It's
not who votes that counts.
"It's who counts the votes."
- "It's who counts the votes."
- I mean, we've been
warned about this stuff.
- Are you surprised that
so many corporations
went woke and went with
this communist ideology
and everything else because
we know it is hurting
their bottom line to an extent.
Disney lost something
like $61 billion
after fighting DeSantis.
We know that all of these
companies, you know,
they put all this product
out there for gay pride month
and nobody buys any of it,
or for black pride month
and nobody buys it,
but they put it out there.
They have to be looking at
the numbers at some point,
but the ideology seems
to have superseded
the whole purpose of
getting into business.
- Well, that's one way of
fighting and back is boycott.
Do you know what I mean?
I'm very careful who I buy from,
and money talks as you know.
But I feel for the
retailers right now,
I go shopping and
everything's on sale.
Why? Because Biden took
the Keystone XL Pipeline,
destroyed it and
then blames Putin
for the high price of oil.
And as I said, I'm
qualified to speak on this
'cause as a graduate of the
U.S. Merchant Marine Academy
at Kings Point New
York, my major was oil.
I drove tankers
for Standard Oil.
I understand oil,
and like the product.
- Do you get worried,
are you getting that
good Japanese A5?
You must be. You must be.
- Well, Dave, I
hate to admit this,
but I've always wanted to
be a Japanese breeding bull,
but I never got to be there.
(both laughing)
- They live a good life.
- You think about it,
man, and all you do
as a Japanese breeding boll,
you sit there and
you have sex all day.
My God.
- That's it.
- That sounds like
Genghis Khan to me.
I wanna do that.
(Dave laughing)
So I am (break in audio
drowns out speech)
- Ah, you're doing all right.
You're doing all right.
- So I invest in Wagyu
breeding bulls you get paid
for the semen, and the semen
then goes into the cows.
I own the cows also.
Then I own the offspring.
That's capitalism.
- Is this all in Japan?
- Huh?
- Is this all in Japans?
- No, it's in Wyoming?
- Oh, so it's, so
you can breed using,
oh, of course, you
can grow Wagyu,
just not specific
Japanese Wagyu right,
that has to be from Japan?
I don't know all the specifics
I just eat it.
- (indistinct)
it's called a brand.
And why Wagyu?
Because rich guys eat Wagyu,
poor people eat hamburger,
okay, or cat food. (laughs)
Look-
- We're gonna be doing
mass cat food for everybody
soon enough, I think.
- I'm unapologetically
a capitalist, but
I want my freedom.
Don't you touch my freedoms.
You wanna eat hamburger,
knock yourself out.
You wanna eat cat food,
- This concept where no
one will own anything,
which seems to be one
of the other things
they're talking about right now,
this must make your blood boil.
- Well, that's that
guy, what's his name,
Klaus Schwab.
- Klaus Schwab, yeah.
- I don't know who that
character is, but my God,
how can it, that's pure Marx.
First thing that Marx said was
abolition private property.
And what Klaus Schwab says is,
"Someday you'll own nothing
and you'll be happy."
And today look at the
younger generation, you know,
the TikTok generation coming up,
they're completely clueless.
When I talk to some
of these young people,
I don't know what the heck
they're watching or smoking,
but they're so out of touch.
- They're watching TikTok.
- Yeah. And TikTok-
- While smoking
varies other things.
- And TikTok is a
Chinese invention
designed to mishmash our brains.
- Yeah, literally, literally-
- So that's why I say
this little iPhone here
is the most powerful
tool ever created.
We've gotta be careful
with it, you know.
So I'm pumping financial
education through it,
but you can pump other
things through it too.
So we need to fight
better by being selective
on what we study, what
we eat, who we support,
who we buy from, 'cause money
does talk, like it or not.
- I like it, I have
no problem with it.
Before we started the show,
I was talking about the
five Gs with my guys.
Can we go through the five Gs?
- Of course I love the five Gs.
- I know, I know.
Take it away.
- Number one is gold.
Gold is God's money.
- It's still worth something.
- Gold is God's money.
It was placed here with silver
when earth was formed.
People say it's 5,000 years old,
no, it's as old as the
earth, gold and silver.
So I own lots of
gold and silver.
I own a gold mine, I just took
a company public last week,
New York Stock Exchange, the
richest gold mine in the world.
It's in Utah, 140-year-old mine.
We applied new technology to it
and we found the richest
veins in the world.
So gold is one.
Grub, Wagyu cattle. (laughs)
This is grub.
- That's at the
high level of grub.
- Or you can eat
hamburger or cat food,
I'd rather have Wagyu. (laughs)
You know what I mean?
Grub, ground: real estate.
Real estate is debt financing.
The reason I invest
in real estate,
as most people know this,
appreciation,
depreciation, amortization,
all of those are tax dodges.
So if I make a million
dollars in the income column,
I need 5 million in debt
in the liability column.
So by taking 1
million to 5 million,
I step up my basis to 6 million.
I depreciate it, I pay no tax.
That's why we-
- And that basically
is what Hillary was
angry at Trump over,
'cause he knew how to do it.
- Yeah, 'cause she's a thief.
- Right. She just takes
other people's money
for the nonprofit.
- Yeah. She wants to attack.
But you know, Trump does
it legally, you know,
she did that uranium Uranium
One with her husband Bill.
So they steal, you
know, it's horrible.
So where was I?
Ground, gasoline: oil, and
then the third one: guns,
fifth one is guns.
So I'm fully armed all
the time, you know,
I was just with Mr.
Shapiro, he's armed.
It's sad that we
have to be this way,
but I'm also a Marine, So
I carry full automatics.
My rate of fire,
I step up the rate of
fire of my machine guns
from about 700 rounds a minute
to 1,000 rounds per minute.
When I buy ammunition,
I buy by the case, I buy
about the pallet load.
- You're not
messing around, man.
- No, I'm like, you know,
Al Pacino in "Scarface".
That's me.
(Dave laughing)
My wife says, "That's
you isn't it?"
He's up there going like
this with he's those guns
going, "Fuck you,
fuck you, fuck you"
That's me.
- Don't leave the
fence open at the end.
- Yeah, I know. (laughing).
- That's the key
to the whole thing.
Every time I leave my house,
I make sure the gate
closes behind me.
- Yeah. It's really
sad, isn't it?
It used to be you could
trust everybody, now it's..
Anyway, that's why I wrote
"Rich Dad, Poor Dad".
That's why I created
the CASHFLOW game.
What the hand does
to mind remembers.
And that's why I support
people like DeSantis and Trump,
because they're capitalists.
We have to support capitalists.
- Are you, do you
consider yourself hopeful?
I mean, obviously
you're concerned
about what's been going
on for this last 90 years,
this march through the
institutions and everything,
but do you consider
yourself hopeful
that we can turn this around?
- Well, we have to do something.
I mean, it seems almost
impossible right now,
especially when my
friend Jim Rickards
announced what Biden
signed into law,
executive order,
March 6th, 2022.
It authorized CBDC, central
bank digital currency,
which is surveillance.
Every country in the
world's doing it now,
China's way ahead of us.
So that's social credit scores
and all those other things
they're going, you know, it's
tied with the little masks,
which everybody
knows don't work.
Or when I saw the doctors
speaking out against COVID
and they got taken down,
that's our freedom.
So I don't care if you're a
Marxist or this or capitalist,
don't take my freedom away.
And if I wanna carry a
gun, let me carry a gun,
don't disarm me.
So that's kind of my, that's
why I'm a U.S. Marine.
I mean, I fought for our
freedom, not for capitalism.
- Do you think we have better
defenses here in the U.S.
that sort of will be the last
stand where other countries,
you know, Canada
doesn't have the,
well, they certainly don't
have the second amendment,
but they don't even have
the defenses around speech.
I mean, we still have
some firewalls left
that a lot of Western
nations don't have.
- Well, I think, like I said,
this tool, this little iPhone
here, most powerful tool,
but it's like a gun,
how do you use it,
to defend yourself
or kill somebody with it?
And so that's why I'm honored
to be on your program.
I commend you.
You have a lot of courage.
And, you know, I'm
on Patrick Bet David
and we're all speaking out.
So they speaking out
on the other side.
This is what they used
to take down Trump
in the social media,
he probably deserved it
of all the things he said.
That's freedom of
speech, you know,
that's all I care about.
We have to fight back.
I don't know if we're
gonna win or lose,
but I'll go down fighting.
That's the difference.
The U.S. Marine, you know,
that's the U.S. Military,
that's most of our
police officers.
So we better fight back,
that's all I'm saying.
Stand up, fight back.
And it starts (break in audio
drowns out speech) when,
I don't know who
labeled them terrorists,
but when the teachers actually
question labeled terrorists
for questioning the teachers,
that's what this book
is about here is,
it starts with the NEA,
Forbes called the NEA,
not the National
Education Association,
National Extortion Association.
We spend more on education
the any country in the world,
and we get a kid who
doesn't know who JFK was.
Oh my God!
- Crazy.
- What are we doing.
- Robert, you're gonna be
very proud of me right now
because not only
am I a capitalist
but I've also started
several businesses,
and I started a tech
company called Locals.com.
We've since merged with Rumble,
I'm sure you're aware of Rumble,
and we're gonna finish up this
interview with two minutes
exclusively for my
Locals subscribers
because I am a true capitalist.
How does that sound?
- That sounds fabulous.
- If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
politics playlists.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists, all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.